you want a sound check mary had a little
lamb' the doctor was surprised I can't
get a joke out of him I'm going to be
talking about the simple W W is for work
and I'm going to consider changes in
work in a rubber band so I'm going to
imagine that I can make a machine out of
a rubber band and the question is if I
add heat to a rubber band does it expand
or does it contract let me show you my
contraption it's this wonderful piece of
apparatus here as described in this
glorious textbook with a diagram showing
a hairdryer a pivot a rubber band and
the meter ruler only I've done it the
other way and this is very good book
written by somebody not million miles
away from me yeah and that's my wife we
wrote it together anyway about 50 P so
you're here trying to flog this on 60 s
yeah it's not not worth it what I'm
going to do is put this rubber band
under tension and I got this industrial
heater which will heat up I can choke
well no I'm not going to show you they
works but I'll get it on your arms does
it it's it hot but now I'm gonna put it
on the rubber band and as a result of
that this will move do you expect it
that could expand or contract I would
expect a rubber band when it was heated
to expand yes okay let's see what
happens as it heats up the rubber band
you can see contracts and there it goes
way up to the top if I can get there
and you can see that the rubber band in
effect has contracted and this pulling
on the rubber band has done work on my
little figure of Robin Hood and made him
rise up so I've actually done work on
him to raise him up if I take him off or
if I put it on there he'll come down the
game ah maybe like Brady you expected
whenever you heat anything it expands
because that's what happens to normal
things like metals if you take a metal
rod heat it up it will move expand and
that's normally what happens but under
these circumstances are having a rubber
band a rubber band is not like a metal a
rubber band is made of long polymer
molecules all stretched out matted
together but there are long molecules so
if you pull this these long twisted
molecules which had tangled up tend to
get straightened out I didn't explain it
better by getting a bit of my wife's
wool when I started the experiment the
rubber band was taught over like this it
was stretched out and now if I heat it
up it gets more disordered it wants to
become more jumbled up like that and as
it becomes more jumbled up it contracts
this is when it stretched out this is
when it's jumbled up why did the
hairdryer make it want to become more
jungle oh well this is this crazy
concept of disorder related to entropy
the hairdryer puts heat in this raises a
disorder of the system and instead of
having it all in a nice straight line it
wants to go into a more crinkly
screwed-up configuration and because of
the sentiment the ends get closer
together and therefore the whole thing
shrinks this is totally counterintuitive
you would have thought heat something up
it's going to expand no this is going to
contract and it's going to do work and
it's going to pull the thing up so you
can convert heat directly into work in
this particular experiment and it's kind
of totally counterintuitive I had this
envision you see that you could have a
little man sitting on there and then it
would rise up and I could get him to
come off and then it would go down again
and then I could heat it up again and
another man would come up
and I invent a perpetual means of
lifting people up from one level to
another because the man is too heavy if
I'd done it in the video I'd had to put
on a tiny little cap like that and then
it wouldn't actually break and fall down
and I can now do it with the cat and the
cat will go up to the top and then I can
take the cap off and then it sink down
as I take off this thing and that cools
down and then I can get another little
man and do the same thing I was in
prison which I know but the concept is
there that this is a machine working in
a cycle I can heat up this it contracts
it goes up I let it cool down it goes
down again I can do some work on an
object and this is the most inefficient
fanciful famous een that you could ever
imagine
that's not no no this is just my strange
imagination work